Zach do we have any other good news was
there anything else that we were looking
at in the news that was interesting
um yeah well uh so it looks they just
tweeted this photo last night of Elon
Musk is training for his fight with Mark
Zuckerberg Friedman
that's awesome now he's training I love
it and I really want to see this fight
because it it will be entertaining
regardless of how good of a fight it is
uh
I thought I read something about how
Elon musk's mom
doesn't want him to fight and came out
and said like the fight is canceled wow
but maybe that's fake news I don't know
I have no idea um yeah I mean it's hard
to know these days what is news what is
being used as like a ploy to push
something
um I think that don't encourage this
match Maya Musk
okay
wow well I think she must know that Elon
I think they say that Zuckerberg can
actually
compete
Mark Zuckerberg he's
a lot younger than Elon right he's only
five seven now elon's 5 10 or 11.
I don't know the weight difference but
if you have a guy that's really strong
that's small I think he's going to
defeat a guy that's weaker that's big
well and also Elon isn't known for being
like a fighter at all and I feel like no
I feel
Mark Like Trains exactly trains he's
like he's like in the Jeff uh Bezos Camp
of like he got rich and then now he just
eat space food and uh treats his body
like a temple yeah I mean Mark hasn't
blinked probably since 91 or 92. yeah I
think he had a surgery yeah yeah I mean
you can see that he's writing an
algorithm with his [__] eyes bro yeah
dude he isn't he is human AI right there
it totally is there's no doubt about it
he very much has an AI look and Elon
looks I think I just don't I don't know
how Elon wins but
if Elon is low-key
I mean he didn't look like he's holding
his boxing gloves correctly if you look
at the boxing gloss Adventure yeah he's
not chin is way out there buddy yeah
that's a great Point even just right
there yeah
and also the age difference that is
something oh that'll wear you oh yeah
yeah uh
but Elon has a gas he ain't stay up all
night and tweet me they gotta tweet it
freaking yeah yeah you're right he's got
gas in the tank so maybe I'm excited to
see he's also a lot heavier it's true so
you know it's a good point you just lay
it on top of him you might win it's a
good point yeah I think it's just
getting interesting in the world this is
the type of stuff you're starting to see
and we talked about this years ago about
everything becoming WWE you know
everything becoming matches it's like
you have uh you know Jake Paul and Nate
Diaz are gonna fight you you know you
have potentially I mean this has
potential you know like Dana White
wouldn't waste his time on the
communicating with these guys
um no I mean I would I want to see it
like it is it is weird
it sort of feels like Hunger Games or
some [__] like
where like they used to make movies or
like in a world where yeah where the two
richest men in the world just duke it
out uh it feels fake you know and it
feels it's so weird now that like
like if me and you wanted to just fight
there we could fight and then we could
like be at Staples Center fighting when
it used to be like you used to have to
be a fighter you would like have to go
through
training for it and just be like me and
you were like yeah similarly built it'd
be like yeah
Theo's got the reach but Adam can get
inside and then and then we could be at
least on an undercard yeah we could be
on an undercard we could be an undercard
for probably like oh maybe who else
could go who who else would be on that
card
I'd like to see Josh Jamel against
somebody
I could I could he's he's a big man too
he's got that long reach big him versus
Dax Shepard
[__] that's a Bangarang right there
yeah we're the undercar people people
are trickling in for us we're trickling
in they're like still or getting their
their drinks and their their foot long
Dodger Dog yeah somebody's explaining to
his wife who we are uh-huh yeah yeah
yeah yeah showing Clips she's like oh I
saw
bumper from Pitch Perfect is fighting
the podcaster guy yeah
yeah honey it's gonna get better honey
yeah better it'll get better it's just
me and you just just dancing around each
other neither of us really wants to
throw a punch you breaking this I hit
you once you break in a song
I spin off
and then who else is on that card who's
under us you said Bangarang what if you
went like old like a Rufio type of like
versus Emmanuel Lewis Maybe
oh is Emmanuel Lewis dead
but hey we're gonna put that out there
if he's not hey sorry whoever brought
Pink's mom to the show they can throw on
stage yeah that's his promoter so
52 52. all right
versus Rufio so if you had them too and
we need a good female ballot on the card
too
yes absolutely uh
Jane Lynch Amy Schumer oh I like that
that's fun
Jane's a little older but she's she's a
tall woman she's longer she's longer and
she she looks like she could go through
a [__] like she could run through a
wall that lady oh she looks like the
like a wind chime that'll beat the [__]
out of some music that is exactly what
she looks like that's a perfect
description of Jane Lynch hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one